Croyez-vous au mal quelque chose d'un
autre monde oui ma sœur parle d'un
tel adjoint qui était le but est là-
bas et il a compris le schéma
de ce que fait cette entité alors il va
enquêter là où il pense que quelque chose de
terrible va se produire ensuite
mon personnage comprend que
certains meurtres non résolus sont liés
aux maisons que personne ne vient jamais ici
vous faire courir à l'intérieur nous rencontrons Courtney et ses
jumeaux vivant dans cette maison qui était
la maison du meurtre pour l'un des
films de Google kill Phyllis tu vas bien
Dylan est  très sensible quand nous arrivons dans
cette maison, quelque chose le dérange, je
m'inquiète pour Dylan, pourquoi il est juste
différent
dans cette maison, ses enfants commencent à se
révéler absolument pour vous montrer en
lui présentant ces films à la maison,
cela élargissait la mythologie en
vous donnant un aperçu de  le premier film sous
l'angle des enfants jusqu'à ce que
vous vous tuiez, vous et toute votre famille,
le deuxième film a le sentiment et l'
ADN du premier film b  mais c'est beaucoup
plus sombre et fidèle à son titre plus
sinistre celui-ci a raison nous allons
montrer au public quelque chose d'
intrinsèquement effrayant et
horrible  et devrait devenir attrape toi
nuit-nuit papa